what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am back
in shortage and we are going to be
interviewing people about their last
relationship and whose fault was it and
is monogamy natural so today we have an
exciting video for you so like the video
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell
started
see the one thing I feel like people
don't see about these type of videos is
that you have to ask a lot of people to
do an interview before someone says yes
so a lot of times you guys just see us
like you know getting the interviews but
you have to be told no like 10 times
before someone says yeah they'll do an
interview hi you guys want to do an
interview for YouTube another question
of today is is monogamy natural no are
you in a relationship uh no I'm not in a
relationship I'm single at the moment
have you ever been yeah yes I have I
have was that not natural for you
it was at the time but the thing is as
I've got an order my mind says
definitely changed when it comes to
monogamy because uh I've seen too many
things and it changes his perception who
cheats more men or women
well I recently saw a study that women
achieved more so I'll say women cheap
more they're more of an opportunity too
that's a thing about it have you ever
cheated no I've always been faithful no
matter what have you ever been cheated
on yes I have how did you find out uh
you start to know his patterns like when
they're not paying attention and then
they want to stop going out more so yeah
so yeah that's how I found out do you
think men are getting a fair deal today
when they have to still provide
provisioning and security but they don't
get Youth and Purity no we're not
getting a fair deal but by that logic
should men uh do you think men should be
faithful if they're in a relationship
that's a tough one I'll say in the west
maybe not but going outside of the West
End yes because you tend to get more
people who are more feminine and more
committed to relationships I mean the in
the west you don't really see that much
nowadays have you ever dated a girl
that's like from like not from here yes
I'm originally from Zambia so I have
dated someone else out of the country
but uh I'll say they've started to adopt
more of a western and tell it you know
so it's definitely changed that's what
I've heard like even outside of the West
like it's getting worse oh yeah
definitely I mean there's a friend of
mine who's going to Asia and he's saying
that it's a much better Prospect over
there to find someone and settle down in
a relationship
[Music]
question of the day is monogamy natural
monogamous
why the hell why why would Logan mean
not natural non-monogamy comes very
easily do you think cheats more men or
women women women women everyone thinks
men do but it's women it's always well
have you ever cheated no yeah
he found out
okay okay thank you guys
Shout Out YouTube Shout Out YouTube the
question of the day is monogamy natural
no no
I don't think it's natural I mean
sometimes I mean yes yes I'll go
opposite do you think it's natural for
men and for women or do you think it's
different no I think it's the same I
think I think it's more natural for
women 100 I don't know I mean I think it
depends on your situation but like I
don't think it's natural like yeah as a
whole have you ever cheated no have you
ever been cheated on
have you have you ever been cheated on
um not like in a relationship but like
like talking sort of thing how did you
find out I mean it's happened like three
times
like through like stories or through
like London isn't that big of a place
like it gets around yeah do you you know
what's the worst day when I found out I
had to worry about ugly girls too you
know what I mean
no one's safe
so question tell me about your first
love I've never been in love never been
in love I would never count it as love
no wow
um what trust issues many trash what did
you have to love them first though to
have trust issues no you know I'm young
I wouldn't say I've been in love have
you been in love
um no I don't know I mean it depends on
the day that you ask
oh yeah oh that's so surprised you guys
are both like pretty girls I just would
have thought we hate men why do you
think why do you guys take that
situation
tips experiences it's not that I hate
men it's just you know well it's just
it's funny it's just funny I hear girls
say that a lot but you don't really hear
guys say that they hate women but
usually when I interview people they say
girls cheat more than guys really yeah I
disagree all right guys all right guys
we have a friend joining us today yes um
my name is anonymous and I'm joking
Michael Michael King King riches you
already know bang bang who do you think
shoots more men or women
um I think it's even it's even yeah like
people act like it's it's guys that do
it but women are really good cheaters if
you didn't know have you ever cheated
yes did you get quiet yeah but I
confessed because I'm a good guy you
told her yeah I told her like an idiot
she told me that uh if she if I told the
truth she ain't she won't get mad
I've used that before I've used that she
said we don't mean it we don't need no
truth I won't get mad I promise and then
as soon as the truth
someone she knew nah it was someone that
I used to sleep with before oh okay so
that okay yeah so so she was kind of
trying to like steal you from the other
girl yeah definitely most definitely and
it worked for a night
and then you woke up and you're like nah
I gotta go no no it was cool but like
you know just gotta move stick and move
you know did you guys break up after
that no I was still sleeping with her
after oh okay so so nothing happened no
no no no no it was like the trust is
gone we're not really on that same level
anymore but were you guys dating or just
talking yeah yeah yeah dating okay
sounds like your girlfriend yeah yeah
she wanted to be up the other girl and I
was like you're not fighting over me for
me is that like an ego boost at all no I
felt great
I said an ego boost yeah yeah yeah it
made me feel like the guy like you know
what I'm saying and I was broke those
times I don't know but I just had bubble
gum that's all I had to offer you know
what I'm saying
some guys in the in the video they're
like must be nice hey it must be not Hey
listen hey have you got the sauce so you
got ketchup I don't know in it like I
don't know I think women cheat more than
men because I think more women can I
think it's it's definitely easier for a
woman to cheat definitely because she
gets Willy thrown at her all day long
you know what I'm saying even if a girl
was a freak she could be a two she'll
still get Willy thrown at her in it so
it's easy like you know what I mean so
if a girl is a two and she's going out
with a goddess of five
and in a guy that's a seven comes along
or a guy like me comes along as our eyes
a slow Tuesday let me I just wanna I
just wanna get my willy wet yeah and
then boom she's gonna do it in it more
than likely see what I'm saying your
last relationship whose fault was it
last one yeah when you guys broke up
who's fault hers 100 why why because she
wasn't good at communicating and she was
always depressed and she was getting on
my nerves so yeah okay
from your experience do you think guys
or girls cheat more which one
guys yeah yeah why'd you say that I
you hear more about guys cheating yeah
yeah so that might not actually be the
truth yeah
yeah because the thing is yeah would you
agree that women have more chance of
cheating because they got more
opportunity
obviously as guys yeah you have to be a
hunter but when you're a girl it kind of
just comes to you because guys are more
need guys are more thirsty yeah yeah not
not me though yeah
yeah have you have you ever been cheated
on yeah what happened uh it's like with
many people behind my back how did you
find out um three's fine oh you went
through his phone yeah no messages
popped up so so basically you you look
was just chilling and his phone was just
blowing up he was in the shower oh
on your forehand why did you stick with
him I don't know what how tall was he
just a bit taller than me a bit taller
was he as tall as me no what would you
rate him out of 10 for looks he was good
looking was he Rich no oh
oh young love puppy love that that makes
sense that makes sense have you ever
cheated no
no it's more guys or girls because um
when they cheat they don't say it but
guys we're open so you're saying
whenever you've cheated yeah you've gone
and said oh I'm cheating but I didn't
cheat I know for me if I cheat I'm not
gonna think oh you know what the first
thing I'm gonna do is tell my girl I
cheated I usually gonna try to keep it a
secret what's gonna happen to you I can
get away with it there are many girls
outside ah then you get another one
oh yeah I'll definitely get another one
so you don't think always cheat that
much nothing Goods cheats on I think I
see it more you think guys yeah
definitely why'd you say that because
they can
because they can because you guys have
got the sauce here
you can say I can't say it like for
everybody but I don't know like the guys
I know okay have you ever cheated on
your girlfriend no never never
all right all right fair enough what
about yourself can you say the same
thing have you ever cheated on a girl
before no comments it's monogamy natural
monogamy I don't know
like what the [ __ ] bro you're like one
man and one woman dating forever is that
natural do you that's what I've got to
say if you want to take a man if you
want to date a woman someone's like two
men one like two women whatever you want
I don't care just be you my babe have
you ever cheated no have you ever have
you ever
all right
why you always lying hi why are your
friends
would like to say on behalf of
wonders I have it I have it
okay okay so so allegedly you haven't
cheated not lying okay they're like okay
okay have you ever been cheated on yes
with four prostitutes what I just had oh
my God bro that happened to me too yeah
okay okay it's a question how did you
find out
um he actually told me I went to drop
off his things and he just sort of
confessed to me and I went home and
cried I'm not gonna lie but now we're
bad bees out here so did you did you
stay with him no if your man cheats on
you get out of there do not go there
again that's what I've got to say
um tell was that your first love yeah it
was actually my first boyfriend's first
love everything but I'm not I'm not
going there again ever again have you
ever cheated I have never cheated and I
put that on God have you been cheated up
yeah I have once or twice but it is what
it is how did you find out my friend
told me your friend how's your friend
find out my friend saw it because I was
in a club and she saw and she sent me
the video then she showed me the video
and it's a little bit awkward but it's
what it is it's got to plan you know
what I mean who do you think cheats more
men or women men men
I think it's equal I actually do think
it's equal I think I think girls admit
when they cheat so they can fix it but
boys just think it's cool playing saline
girls whatever but boys don't girls
cheat and get away with it boys make it
so obvious but girls just come and come
out with it they either admit or they
don't they never find out I think it's
more natural to us to learn like figure
[ __ ] out where medic goes over their
heads so like a girl a guy's not gonna
really go through your phone but a
girl's gonna yeah I saw the DMS from 45
weeks ago I saw you texting Rose X Leah
who was that Mr
sir who is this sir out of all of your
boyfriends what percent did you go
through their phone
I've had one boyfriend and I did go
through his phone but I was correct to
do so because he did cheat on me so I
did find that out with my co-worker you
seen it with your co-worker with my
co-worker and I had to go into work like
a couple weeks later and it was really
awkward so but I left the job I quit so
have you ever gone through a boy's prom
I went through one boy's phone and
that's because I knew he was lying to me
so I had to just double check and I was
right girls are always right so what if
you found nothing would you have told
him then I can't lie I would have been
listening I went through your phone I'm
really sorry like I didn't realize what
I was doing you know I'd apologize I'd
fall from confessed what I done and I'd
apologize I had a hundred percent
comparison I have nothing to fly about
if I'm suspicious I'll tell you I'm
suspicious and I'll I'll go through my
Sherlock home sort of face and I'll find
out why I'm especially Mr Man but it's
the men who say you can't go on my phone
you can't live through my feet they're
the ones who are hiding stuff what are
the best apps to look in if you're gonna
look through a guy's phone where where's
the cheating
and then go through what pictures
they've liked because they normally go
back and like the girls that you they
told you not to worry about whoever you
ever go through who they follow and like
see yeah yeah a girl tip if you log on
to Instagram Through Safari you can see
the most recent follower you can see who
they most recently followed what do you
think the best apps girls should look
through to catch you you said you
cheated so so what app should we be
looking through Snap obviously because
it disappears come on
if you see a purple open Snap you know
your partner's been doing the day listen
if they've got snap period like you're
in trouble you know what I'm saying but
if this messages are gone then where do
you look Instagram that's the next one
that's the next one to hit up the DMS in
it wait listen if you're trying to find
a cheetah yeah you need to go through
everything WhatsApp DMS snaps regular
messages everything man that's fine guys
don't do it that's a girl thing because
guys yeah because you think too much of
yourself you think you're just great and
you're great oh my God unlimited Source
yeah unlimited source.com why girls this
is why girls go through your phone
because you're too cocky about it do you
pick the guys that cheat though like if
you're gonna cheated on like can't you
say you pick them would you guys would
you guys go on a date with him after
that answer no no why why but like look
you've said you've got too much
sauce.com yeah I can share the sauce
with you in it I would not you wouldn't
no no so it's hard now access denied
okay
do you think though that we should take
accountability for the men we picked
though so for picking like because I
think girls I think girls know on some
level who's gonna cheat I feel like my
skills no but you know what some boys
hide it very very well and then you find
out later on when you're already in love
so you're already attached to them so
there's nothing you can really do not
know I feel like girls get attached too
quick and boys get attached too late
that's how it goes I agree by the time
the girl is over the boy the boy is
hooked on the girl if only we could
start synchronizing that it would be
great smooth and cognac I'm a big threat
yeah I just came to sightseeing get your
[ __ ] wet oh
that's a big Flex stop going up like six
eggs you see the drip wrist sweat heard
somebody said that I ain't made a hit
yet had to hit them back with a quick
text [ __ ] couldn't tell from these big
checks oh yeah nay Rose and I'm back at
it yeah back at it scale of one to ten
how hard was it to get her detail nah
that was pretty simple man it just asked
for the name contacts you get me I told
you unlimited source.com
do you think they were capturing when
they said they don't like cheaters most
definitely they love bad players and
what do I look like come on
[Music]
that's why it's the goat s
you are awesome
I feel like it sounds stereotypical but
I think women are more slime with it
these guys are kind of crazy like I've
seen before in a crazy thing so I can I
kind of tested that who did you cheat
with I got caught because I just left
the messages on my phone like you know I
mean like when you when you cheat
mentality you're off anyway like
mentally off so like obviously I cut off
an end because mentally you're not there
if you cheat that's my personal opinion
you feel like you would have cheated
anyways or do you feel like it was
because of problems in the relationship
there was no problems I think at the
time I was younger a lot younger so I
kind of like the attention so like I was
kind of susceptible to it whereas now
attention to tension it doesn't phase me
I'm a little older than I'm 26 so it
don't bother me but when I was younger
any attention that I I liked I would
have gone for it but you know you grow
up you get older you mature there's not
there's nothing she could have did no
nothing she could have done you know I
mean she couldn't she was perfect you
know what I mean like I look back at it
it's nothing she done wrong genuinely
I'll just meet us being a [ __ ] person at
the end of the day so she went through
your phone that's how she caught you
yeah it always I was deleting my
messages I got the point where I was so
comfortable she never checked my phone
so I got the point where I had to stop
deleting them and then next thing you
know I remember the one day I didn't
delete it was the one day shots to go
for my phone so I took it as fate you
know what I mean because for like six
months I was deleting it she didn't go
for my phone six months you got away
with it yeah and then one day I did I
didn't get the messages and that same
night I didn't delete it I pulled out to
a house I was like I'm not doing these
messages anymore got in the house 10
minutes later oh she's like your phone
have you ever been cheated on uh not
that I know of well probably I'll
probably set that like that's what it is
you know I mean there's obviously
there's a good looking guys out there I
am perfect at the end of the day so you
know I mean I'm humble and I really like
it you take a girl back if she cheated
on you uh probably not nah do you think
a girl should take you back if you cheat
she shouldn't but she doesn't
appreciative anyways
it's more men or women
yeah
who do you think is more opportunity to
cheat men or women women so then by then
wouldn't you think they would do it more
no because when women like someone they
like someone do you think women like
most of the men they're with
either waiting for something better to
come along no
otherwise why would you give them the
time of day money dinner I mean you've
never heard of girls like not
statistically girls make like 10K less
than guys yeah but I would never say to
a guy I want you could see your money
you don't hear that all the time on like
social media like girl says get that bag
get the money yeah but that's talking
about getting it with themselves it's
not about men getting it for them no
you've never heard of like foodie calls
women go on dates for the food yeah yeah
free food and stuff but I wouldn't do
that but that's not their boyfriend I'm
not saying yeah but I see girls like
they get their rent paid for by a guy
and they're like screwing the guy they
actually like Standish yeah I mean if he
wants to yeah if he wants to but you
wouldn't pretend to like someone okay
tell me tell me a question tell me about
your first love
thank you it was love I think it was the
last it was last yeah did he cheat
yes how'd you find out I met her yeah
that's why we're friends oh wait so you
guys are screwing the same guy no I
didn't I didn't [ __ ] him okay
and then I message her and then I found
out about her and now we're friends well
he didn't forget about you
do you still talk to him the guy
you ever been cheated on yeah how did
you find out he had a fake Snapchat and
I found it did you get in his phone yeah
so he had a whole fake identity and
um
he wanted gothamone's brother's name for
some reason I don't know where but yeah
do you think monogamy's natural
it's because it's a made-up concept I
think it's a made-up concept do you
think it's not natural for men and women
why because we're
winning I'm a man have you ever cheated
yes did you get caught yes how did you
get my phone how did you get in it you
never passcode I did but they knew my
passcode did you give it to her yes why
would you give him your passcode if you
were cheating I was planning to end the
things that messy ever been cheated on
yes did you find out I have him right in
front of me
it was a long time ago it's fine how did
how did it happen like he hooked up with
someone
you kill a person right in front of me
yeah
did you punch someone I would oh my God
what yeah yeah how'd you find out
oh I'm a woman if a girl if a girl ever
if a girl has a feeling it's just yeah
we go through phones I'm not saying it's
right sorry to my to my ex I did go
through your phone
um
I wasn't a proud moment you know
that's my red flag for the internet
that's my red black
monogamy's natural yeah yeah
no no I think so have you ever cheated
not no no have you ever been cheated on
yes yes no
how did you find out
watch out the girl so the girl reached
out to you
and did you go through his phone no I
saw a video of it
it came up and saw my story
it came on like some your friend was
someone that you both knew recorded him
cheated yeah you saw it yeah like was he
like screwing someone in the video I'm
kissing oh oh it was like in the
background at a party yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh my God what'd you do I just says
did you break up with him or you stay we
break up then and then what who do you
think cheats more men or women men men
think about it I have to think about it
I think men do I think women cheat more
you have to a guy has to be at a certain
level for you to hook up with him most
guys can't cheat I think most men would
but I think most women like can cheat
and they have like they go out the door
they have men throughout yeah I think
like I don't know there's like a thing
that comes with cheating for women that
doesn't with men where men it's like oh
my God no way like you did that or
something it's like okay you're a [ __ ]
like so I think it tends to be like
maybe like a bit of like a moral
difference maybe I think like if girls
get more opportunity every day like it's
it's like okay if you have the
opportunity to steal every single day
but one gender has the opportunity to do
it way more than the other I just think
that gender is going to do it more
because I think people are shitty both
ways I think I think it's men I think
it's it's a socialized thing I think
it's men I still think it was
[Music]
yeah so let me ask you again who cheats
more men or women women what you're
saying women cheat more yeah I just said
that oh wow that's not no usually girls
will say guys in it you ever cheated no
have you ever been cheated on no wow
you're lucky then but why do you say
girls cheat more because they're just a
little bit sneaky they're sneaky yeah
what do guys need to look for Snapchat
Snapchat that's the one Snapchat listen
I already said if your girl's got
Snapchat bro it's Danger Above you
better be going through that bro the
messages disappear you don't know what's
going on out there man you have Snapchat
yes would I delete my Snapchat yeah no
if you think a guy can love a girl and
still keep Snapchat yeah cool [ __ ] he
just needs like the side chicks listen
it's not all about side chicks and
cheating you know we use Snapchat to
keep in communication with people you
just had a contradicting what you said
listen it's not about me yeah who do you
think cheats more men or women woman
why'd you say that right you know those
chicks once again in the club they're
like yeah can you get me a drink and
stop now oh so when they get in the club
they forget they got a man probably yeah
well they're for everyone yeah probably
oh that's mad that's mad streets are
wild the streets are wild do you guys
think monogamy is natural
oh just one by one have you ever cheated
yes I'm not surprised [ __ ] no
who cheats more men or women men of
course you think so oh isn't that
obvious
no because women are sneakier yeah I
think so too have you ever gone through
a guy's phone what'd you find
who is he sleeping with who is he
sleeping with I don't even know what to
start from I was I was just really upset
honestly yeah have you ever cheated
did you get caught no have you ever
caught a guy cheating not at the time he
did it but I found out later how did you
find out uh his wife messaged me did you
have a kid no no have you ever been
cheated on yeah how did you find out
texts yeah on the phone did you go
through his phone yeah but you know I
had a hunch so I had to follow it if you
went through his phone and found nothing
would you tell him and give him like
some sort of reward like good job no no
no no he doesn't need to know
who cheats more men or women
um who cheats more men and women
why
can't help the grass on the other side
and it's not Green's gross off the grass
is green
what did you say the grass is green on
the other side but it's not okay have
you ever cheated on someone no I've been
cheating on
them so you've been cheated on how did
you find out I went for his phone you
went for his phone what was it snap or
install snap so snaps always IV photos
IB fancy Menchie Well why'd you say that
bro
mad I love the honesty
he's gone he's gone I love the honesty
an ugly one man one woman for life is it
natural
[Music]
yeah have you ever cheated no no
no comment that means he has have you
ever been cheated on
um no that moral what no I'm allowed oh
that's good yeah most girls I've talked
to today have been cheated on so that's
awesome oh good I hope that happened do
you think monogamy is natural at a
certain point yeah at a certain point
what point is that once you've got it
out your system I think it's time so
once you've got the hot girl summer out
your system then it's okay yeah yeah who
cheats more men or women men why'd you
say that because they do
no well why do you think why okay so as
a man cheated on you before no no
that would cheat on me all right but
have you ever cheated though no you sure
yeah yeah okay more men or women both
have you ever cheated before yeah have
you ever been cheated on yeah okay how
did you find out when you've been
cheated on I found out myself sometimes
was a feeling and then I found out
proofs how did you get the proof through
his phone obviously you went through his
phone was he asleep not always sometimes
I asked him and then he would be like no
no no and that would make me think like
okay if you say no that means you're
hiding something okay so why did you
cheat on the person you cheated on
because it was such a toxic relationship
I got cheated so many times then at the
end I was like
which is bad which is very bad I know
but sometimes they happen okay the guy
that the guy that was cheating on you
what would you rate him out of ten two
no it looks it looks zero zero so you
date zeros so if you used to date me
you'd be punching in it no because you
said you date zeros and I know I'm not
zero I think people from their
personality looks it doesn't
matter so looks don't matter to you the
eyes does one hits Parts but it's not
the most important thing so would you
date a guy shorter than you if I really
like his personality what do you say so
mainly no I have to be honest so it
looks do Madden yeah yeah you said look
don't matter the I want his part but if
I find somebody where I have a lot of
chemistry or like his personality then
it doesn't matter whether he's shorter
or not though my art and it's all about
personality but then it is about looks
these girls saying looks don't matter
they're capping they're capping it's
funny because this is what it is the
girls will be sleeping with someone out
of their league and then they'll go down
to a guy that's on their league that's
gonna like date him and they'll think
they're like punching down but really
you're just punching on your level you
wanna she didn't want to say how
good-looking he was for my estimation it
was probably a good looking dude in it
that's why she stuck around it's more
men or women men I would say man yeah
have you ever been cheated on
have you ever seen someone cheat yeah
man or a woman man
you get caught yeah yeah how do you get
caught oh the the women checked the
phone I think he was speaking about it
quite publicly so she knew have you ever
been cheated on
how would you find out the girl's friend
messaged me the girl's friend did you
stay with him yeah I think I did I think
women like cheater because if we didn't
like cheaters why does everyone date one
yeah
whose fault was your last breakup my
exes why she cheated well how would you
find out no like my boy told me like my
boy saw a cheat in Macy at like a bar or
something no like he saw her like taking
a rock taking her out and then literally
like he said he saw her and then he sort
of going into Auto like a Travelodge and
you know what happens then
who cheats more men or women women
monogamy natural I don't even know what
that means I don't know probably not
probably not
now not now have you been cheated on no
what about you what do you think men or
women cheat more men why because you've
been cheated on yeah
oh they've been caught easier how do you
think men get caught the easiest
well like women
so women are sneaky some not to be
trusted
some are you sneaky no are you sneaky
you don't oh yeah so what you've never
cheated now
have you ever cheered how many
boyfriends have you had two
okay so in the last relationship who
messed up my
Ed what did he do
what
he had a bad attitude yeah treated you
like crap yeah how long was he with him
a few years why did you stay with him if
he treated you like crap because I was
young oh okay okay was he really really
good looking no
no who cheats more men or women women
for sure why it's just so easy in it
like what hey do you want to meet yeah
of course there spread them have you
ever caught a girl cheating no but if I
did I'd cry
have you ever cheated
you guys ever cheated I'm leaving now
have you have you ever have you ever
cheated
have you ever have you ever been cheated
on oh absolutely yeah how did you find
out Dean I've seen and then I found out
on film my ex told me your ex told you
yeah and your last relationship your
last breakup whose fault was it oh
absolutely his why because he's an
[ __ ] do you break up with him or he
break up I'll broke with him because he
is a massive [ __ ] what did he do how
long were you with him what did he do
yeah yeah what did he do yeah what did
he do oh it just like sleeps around
didn't it he cheated you caught him
cheated how long were you with him yes
was it the first time yes it's always
years the guy's a bad guy and they're
always moving for years think about it
do you think because you were with him
for years maybe you liked the drama of
being cheated on and being like I left
him as soon as it happened okay oh my
God yeah
after it happened I left that was the
first time you caught him yeah obviously
then go on bye see you later goodbye see
you later go to bed that anyway that's
your time to go okay when you caught him
did you like were you living together no
you know oh my God you know the worst
thing is you stay with my mother we hate
her right hey yo what the [ __ ] we hate
him he cheated with your mother he was
staying with my mother oh he was staying
with your mother she with my mom and dad
yeah they had us the first half I'm not
gonna lie man you you should compromise
your living situations for some box
ready ready ready ready oh Chiefs more
men or a woman woman
why have you ever been cheated on yes
yes how did you find out she got
pregnant it wasn't mine
damn who cheats more men or women
yeah emotionally we can cheat but men
can just cheat just to cheat so what
you're saying is men can like go like
your man or maybe not your man I don't
want to get known in trouble can I have
a girlfriend sleep with another girl and
just feel nothing feelings yeah 100 and
what you're saying a girl can't do the
same thing I know unfortunately no okay
so do you think men or women cheat more
which one man man why'd you say that
emotion behind it is just purely sex
which is yeah but don't you think women
will have more opportunity to cheat yeah
because men are always moving to women
however women if women cheat it will be
with one man only then they don't
differentiate they just cheat just to
cheat you're going on like a lot of guys
can do it though not every guy's got the
sauce have you been cheap have you been
have you been cheated on
absolutely no have you done any cheating
emotionally yes oh emotionally yeah can
you explain and did you get
how did you find out he cheated
serious so so what did you stay with him
or did you kick did you kick him to the
curb you came to the curve wow how did
you do it text face to face all of the
above all at the same time so he was
texting him and tell him at the same
time what hey that's mad that's mad
that's mad you've been cheated on no I
don't think no I don't know
I know more men I think you know a lot
of guys that cheat on their girls no but
what are you saying I think I know more
men than women I have no more women so
so in your in your mind women don't
really cheat they do so who did she who
cheats one in your opinion men or women
men okay okay okay have you ever been
cheated on I don't think so I might have
been have you ever gone through a guy's
phone no well so you just have perfect
relationships don't you no if I don't
trust them and then I'm like ah you know
we'll either your last relationship how
did it end did both mutually broke up it
was both toxic we just weren't shouldn't
have been in a relationship all right
how tall are you five ten would you date
a guy that's five ten yeah would you
date a guy that's five eight yeah okay
so there's no minimum requirement there
is a minimum what's the minimum probably
under that do you think uh nice guys
finish last no not they've got the right
people right people what do you mean I
forgot nice people
nice people you like nice guys yeah yeah
do you think I'm a nice guy probably
I don't think so I look like a nice guy
I mean
I mean like nice people I think they act
like that I don't know how do you tell
from looks that's a good we've got a
smart one okay okay
fault was your last breakup
who cheats more men or women me what's
the wildest way you've cheated you ever
cheated with a girl's relative or
roommate no no no no no it was always
girls she didn't know yeah yeah smarter
yeah did she did she catch you what did
she catch you cheating yeah how text
yeah was she cheating too or just you no
no have you ever been cheated on I don't
know who cheats more men or women men I
would say women have you ever cheated no
absolutely not have you ever caught a
guy cheating yes yes how I sort of had
Lincoln didn't really actually catch him
but he was shaking his ex behind my back
the whole time two days before we went
on holiday and I managed to catch him
out after that wait did you go through
his phone yeah I did afterwards
um I also knew that she was at his house
how because I see it on Instagram oh I
see you looked at our story
what about you how did you catch him
actually I was seeing someone recently I
turned onto his football game to
surprise him and there was another girl
sitting there watching him
goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
you say hi to her like how did it I knew
that I was like we went to school
together who are you here to watch and
she said the name and I was like me too
you guys confront him after yep I think
she's with him now oh she stayed with
him so why do you you said women cheat
more why do you think that is because I
think they can get away with it men
don't really go through our phones
that's like a woman yeah and I also
think men are stupid and they leave that
trial behind whereas women are quite
clever and can easily just sort of get
away with it oh that's my boy best mate
or whatever it is you know someone that
slow I've uh not baiting any of my
friends out but have you have you seen
that happen where a girl will sleep with
her ex or her boyfriend's friend not
necessarily friend but I've seen like
someone with someone not that he knows
but she someone she worked with
in it also it all happened that way did
he find out I don't think so did she
leave only because he broke up with her
before she had the opportunity to leave
whose fault was your last breakup and my
exes is the one that cheated yes yes do
you think it's ever our fault for
getting cheated on if we're not doing
our part in a relationship no no
you're not I'm not saying with you guys
but like I think leave yeah it's very
true what do you think about guys that
cheat because their wife won't sleep
with them they say one out of four
marriages is sexless on the woman's part
I don't even know what to say about that
that's wrong it's very wrong you say it
would you would you say on both sides or
no uh no because I think men are more
like being in a relationship but I can
understand but then they're in the wrong
relationship because then why wouldn't
you want to sleep with your boyfriend I
think the issue is that like a lot of
them don't want to ruin it for the kids
so like if they leave and so but it's
like I've talked to guys I'm not happy
split up that's gonna be the best
outcome for your kids like don't stay
together because not statistically you
play a kid at every statistical
disadvantage including you're more
likely to go to prison more likely to
drop out of school more likely to be
homeless if you have the dad out of the
home so like a lot of guys think about
like their kids first and so that's why
they don't want to leave but their wife
isn't sleeping with them it's a hard one
is it a heart that's like I mean I guess
like you can still say like my ex like
he cheated on me and he didn't have a
mother figure so whether it was like the
mum figure like not being around that
might have been the reason why I don't I
really don't know I think it's a hard
one to specify no comment who cheats
more men or women
why'd you say that
[Laughter]
but won't you see yeah that women will
have more chance to cheat women
win more chance cheaper do they take it
no men do have you been cheated on not
oh
much
mad mad mad mad mad who cheats more men
or women
that cheat more women but but you don't
get caught we don't get caught and the
thing is like it doesn't matter like
what doesn't matter what do you mean it
don't matter oh that woman cheating
yeah but don't you think no one should
be cheating oh yeah
oh yeah she said oh yeah she said oh
yeah no one should cheat do you think do
you think it's natural to stick with one
person it is it's different for
different people I think all right what
about you what do you think oh yeah I
want to be with one person yeah okay let
me ask you this how tall are you uh five
nine all right so uh what's the minimum
height a guy has to be to date you
he said it right six foot so you would
so you wouldn't date a guy that's five
foot ten no I would you know what it's
like love is more than high love is more
than high so it looks don't matter no
no I didn't hide I might say looks don't
matter I'm saying love is more than hate
so looks do matter
yeah I'm confused I'm confused right now
G which one's more important the looks
or the personality there's a lot
of things learns personality bank
account oh oh bank account okay so how
much money does a guy need to be making
today
she's not joking about she's not joking
bro you have far more privilege being a
woman than he does you walk into it you
no no I'm not here I'm telling you you
all can do it you walk into a room
people look at you they're giving you
the benefit of the day like you're
beautiful yeah but I'm saying like it
was here yeah the white man what do you
mean I've got more privileges than him
because you're a woman you're a young
woman you're a young woman
sexual though I'm just saying in general
the world treats you better if you're an
attractive girl
pretty privilege is real yeah I'm not
saying it's not real but men demand
power like they're present alone like is
just powerful a small percentage of men
not most men
hashtag all men all of them all of them
all of them
all the power
patriarchal society no we look I think
we will actually live in a women make 70
to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions so so so our whole the gender
pickup doesn't exist actually in certain
cities women out earn men if you take
into account the number of hours worked
and the jobs that they pick so like for
example there's a building being built
next to where I live I don't see a
single woman working on it so they're
going to get paid more if they're doing
harder jobs
but that's a really subjective one-off
anecdotal story about a building that's
been built and women don't work in
construction that's what you're telling
me women don't work in construction true
fine right right
the gender pay Gap is real the gender
pay Gap exists so I have a question yeah
I have a question if if you have both
are working the same job yeah and you
work 30 hours a week yeah and he works
40 hours a week yeah do you deserve to
be paid as much as him no I'm sorry how
how many hours are we contract
contracted for so I'm saying if you're
in a salaried position right you start
off
exactly the same job actually
okay okay so I'm saying let's say you
both make 40 000 pounds a year let's
just let's just say set yeah and let's
say on that salary job you work 30 hours
a week and he works 40. let's just say
that yeah and at the end of the year he
gets a bigger raise than you is that
fair because he worked more hours but
why are you presuming that he worked for
more hours okay and what what if I work
30 hours a week but I also do lots of
unpaid Child Care can you can you can
you okay I need you to acknowledge the
first point would you say that's fair
yes yes so that's what's happening as
men work longer hours yes so when they
ask women how many hours they work and
the same job as a man when they when
they they say to women how many hours do
you work and they say to men how many
hours do you work the women work Less
hours self-reported they work Less hours
because I need to go home and clean a
house and raise some children as well as
work in a full-time job because of
gender roles because of gender roles I
do a lot I'm not saying I have children
but hypothetically I do a lot of unpaid
child care I do a lot of unpaid
housework I do as well as a salaried
role so if we hypothetically have the
same job but he works more hours is
because he has a privilege to work more
hours and to put more into his job and
and climb the ladder because he's a man
who has male privilege what is this it's
not even accounting for race privilege
actually what is stopping you from
staying from from working and reach out
and cleaning the house gender pain
gender roles so I'm saying what's
stopping you from having the husband
stay home there's nothing stopping you
thank
Society doesn't we are bound to gender
roles we're not though like if I if I
because I'm I'm I'm so if I if I date
someone and I want to work and he I I do
well on YouTube right I could have a
house husband if I want to or but that's
yeah but that's what I'm saying there's
nothing stopping you which is
but Society doesn't make it easy not
just my personal style yes Society does
not make it easy
men are not conditioned to be
people who do unpaid child care and
unpaid housework they're not conditioned
because we live in a in a patriarch
society that engenders men into gendered
positions where they don't do that
therefore they can work 40 hours if
that's true then why are there quotas
for women
Society is pushing this why are there
why are there quotas we're going to get
into the whole positive discrimination
gender roles
who teach more men or women
[Music]
why'd you say that
women are more loyal do you think so
yeah because it'd be hard for a woman to
go out and cheat like compared to a man
did you
think it's hard for it's hard for a
woman to cheat yeah but wouldn't you say
that like women get more dick thrown at
them than men get [ __ ] thrown at them
like think about your own life how many
guys are probably on your case in your
friend zone women will find it hard
no we'll find it easier to say no
compared to men easier okay okay let me
ask you a question your last
relationship what who who was the one
that messed it up you or the guy never
been in a relationship before oh okay
okay okay so how so how do you know that
men cheat more from
um seeing like you've been watching TV
watching TV and friends like their
stories and stuff so I just seen like
okay what about you did you mess it up
did you miss out your last relationship
no he kind of dead so it's not me
it was him yeah what did he do
did he cheat no did you cheat no have
you ever cheated no
boom who cheats more men or women men
all right why do you think that men
cheat more than because they do just
natural it seems like
are you saying that from experience have
you been cheated on no you don't need to
be you don't need to you don't need to
have been cheated on to not mention you
do you think nice guys really finish
last no you like nice guys 100 who
doesn't like
him the only problem is that some of
them are just not attractive
men really cheat more when one out of
three men are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year or 80 of women
are sexually active well that's really
embarrassing stats
embarrassing for who though
[ __ ] really wanted nice guys through
there but like they don't women don't
want the nice guys because they only
swipe right about five to ten percent of
the time so the reason women think like
men are trash is because we're all
[ __ ] the same ones maybe you are
that's one way people are meeting is
online 100 I hear that yeah me I'm
talking personal in it I'm not talking
in general but for all your
ex-boyfriends are nice guys I have one
ex-boyfriend and he wasn't
why is your ex-boyfriend then if he was
a nice guy
work out he messed up you're him Mutual
you both toxic not woo why is that word
have to come into it all right you both
messed it up so you're both fat fully
mean yeah 100 I believe that when you
had a conversation with the partner as
to why the actual situation broke up
yeah on a scale of one to ten how
attractive was he 10 being awesome one
being 8.5 8.5 how tall are you five foot
two how tall was the guy five eleven oh
okay um and it was 8.5 okay how long was
he moving for four years
five yeah you should lock that one down
was that little external things get in
the way of a relationship it's not
always as easy as oh my gosh I think
it's attractive and oh my gosh he thinks
I'm attractive but we've got great
personality we click there's sometimes
external factors that can ruin our
relationship to you yeah see like that
sounds like like nothing my girl I've
heard girls say this so they're like it
doesn't mean anything to you yeah that's
what I'm asking like what does that mean
well without putting my business out
there that's why I'm saying it so
vaguely yeah what's the minimum height I
got a guy has to be today
um I like tall men I'm attracted to
taller men how tall are you again five
foot two carry on okay say my height
means nothing that's what I'm attracted
tall enough
so I was right so I was right how much
money do you think a guy needs to be
making to date you more than me
okay I'm not gonna save my salary
so if a guy so if a guy so if a guy was
making less money than you would that be
automatic disqualification yeah because
I know it can cause problems in a
relationship but basically what you're
saying is if a guy's making less money
you can't really respect him like that
as your guy okay your point was no I'm
just I'm just asking I'm asking it's not
about respect it's just about I know
that it's going to cause problems in
relationship because I've been there
that will happen in the in the last
relationship I said I'm thinking again
you're trying to put my best out there
but I didn't say that
okay if I was trying to holler at
YouTube would I be tall enough
you're just you're not my type well in
the face yeah
yeah oh okay what about you no
disqualified it's okay
no you you you just call it my niece I'm
disqualified myself I'm disqualified
myself in it come on
let me turn around
yeah yeah you look like someone I can
work out with no so anyway what's your
details what's your details so I can
speak to you again and what was your
name again
yeah you
cheats more men or women men girls
because that's Nikia for you guys to
like because I'd imagine with 1.4
million on Tick Tock you guys are
getting hit up every single day yeah I
think you guys are stunning too so it's
like I'm sure yeah
so so
like is it hard to pick a guy because
there's so many that are coming at you
all yeah but then I just feel like with
me like I pray quite a lot so if someone
comes my way I feel like it is from God
sometimes so I'm just very cautious
though because some people are there for
the wrong reasons they're for clout yeah
I guess so and you can tell they when
like they're there for cloud so but like
I'm I know quite a lot if they're there
for the wrong reasons so yeah you guys
get nervous like someone will go out if
you do something with a guy like they'll
go on Tick Tock and like since before I
was always out and I'm gonna beat myself
out here but I was kissing someone in a
club and it got filmed and then I was
like why did why did your boy's film it
for and he was like oh like I didn't
know but I think like they did they
planned it or something so a bit
embarrassing but he wouldn't delete it
as well so I'd be like you're very weird
what about you is it hard to pick a guy
with so many that are coming at you all
the time or is there one that like
stands out and then you're upset I think
like I have like my favorite and I'll
just go for my favorite one how many
favorites have you got
one right now my favorites do you have
five five
what does a guy have to like have to
stand out to you I like someone that's
ambitious someone that's Godly as well
that's very important to me and someone
that is quite family orientated I'd say
Godly I like why man to be caring yeah
and honest and loyal and respectful you
guys ever gone for the same guy once we
actually did get an argument because
basically I was in a cab and then the
guy was liking her photos but I think he
wasn't sure if it was me or her and then
I ended up like like dancing with him
and she got really upset with me she she
had a little boy she was talking to so I
was like at least give me a break and
then we have some fun the nice guys
finish last so you only date nice guys
you've never dated no bad boys I have
but I prefer like nice voice okay okay
do I look like a nice guy no you look
nice you look a bit annoyed but a bit
naughty is good A bit naughty the right
the right I told you unlimited source
foreign
but anyway so boom so what do you like
uh Bad Boys
how can you be bad and be good at the
same time it's one or the other I think
you can be both I'm not sure I like more
of like good bad boy there's gonna be a
mixture not just one what like me
huh you can find out in it
don't hold it she's talking about they
want a Godly guy was the last time you
were at church I'll go to church every
Sunday and bible studies Wednesdays
Bible studies what was the last uh
lesson that you learned about temptation
of trying to fight it oh what was you
there together just you on your own I
know we do it together oh okay okay can
I join yeah
he's cool I'm there
bye boys
you like bad boy yeah you like bad boys
I can see in your eyes so what not what
what they always say nice guys finish
last what is that true or false no
comment well there you go there you go
bro that's the honest that's the honest
truth though who cheats more men or
women it depends it depends it depends
even it equals 50 50. so why is it that
that people always say that Menchie
usually the people I hang around with
that that doesn't personally I feel like
it doesn't happen what's up
why do people because they get bored
with a beautiful wife it doesn't matter
whether you beat them up it doesn't
matter
cheating doesn't mean anything to them
but all right if you want to go down
that road then let people say like men
go oh it's different for a woman like
when women cheat to a man cheats
different because okay if you cheat with
a guy he has to be at a certain level
for you to cheat with him like he's got
to be a certain height he's got to be a
certain level of attractiveness he has
to be have a certain level of ambition
I'm not saying all of them but he has to
have some you're not you're not cheating
with an ugly broke bomb like you're not
but a guy will cheat with an ugly fat
like an ugly girl
okay guys thank you for watching another
episode of Street talks where are the
streets they talk what do you think of
today it was an awesome time you know I
got a couple numbers couple digits and
put in some work because I've got
unlimited source.com
four for four on numbers I've seen you
get all right receipts I told you guys
already I'm real I'm out here I'm doing
this and I you know now got the receipts
you know I'm saying Witnesses all of it
so we do have an exciting new a new
announcement for the channel so
um in our new content Studio we're
actually signing different talents onto
the team and Michael is starting a new
Channel with us he's one of the first
people are you excited I am Hey listen I
can hardly contain myself bursting that
seems it's crazy no but I'm really
excited um it's a great opportunity and
I'm ready to work and get this get this
moving you guys don't forget to like the
video subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and we'll talk to you
next time